[Music]
are there any other apologies no all
right um
i'll move those apologies
all those in favor
against carrot
are there any conflicts of interest
okay
thank you brent
right confirmation of minutes from the
18th of october meeting i recommend that
we confirm those minutes all those in
favour oh a second to please
thank you john seconded by john all
those in favor
against
any matters arising from the minutes
it doesn't seem to be
right we've got no deputations and
presentations today so we'll move
straight on to
item number five adjourned business
which is we just had
a workshop on this so
we have the amendment to the
discretionary grant funding criteria so
would someone like to move
either a
b with c
mhm
grants will not be accepted if the
applicant has applied to more than one
community board's discretionary fund
i've got a written year
more than one
community board's discretionary
we're doing
right so that new one added to that and
al has seconded that so neville
well i i've been a long believer that
the grants fund was put there for small
community groups to come to us
and
get funding
to help them out with uh with what it is
they're doing i don't believe it was
ever set up for community boards and its
totality
to uh to apply to each community board
and end up with a two thousand dollar
grant i believe that should be uh
something that is back in council's
hands
and council should or should not
make a decision on whether they should
do that hence the reason for d
the others as we discussed in the
workshop i don't have have an issue with
i think that uh
the discretion there with the with c so
i
have no problem with that discretion of
um discussing the schools is no
particular problem
but
as i say for four groups uh sorry for
one group to go to four different uh
community boards to get funding i think
has always been
uh in my view has some something that
i've never never agreed with
thank you nabal al would you like to add
to that nothing to add so i'll put the
motion
oh
philip
yeah i don't get a vote madam chair but
i don't support the amendment or d
um it is a discretionary fund and we do
have the discretion to approve or not to
approve
there are occasions where multiple
applications are appropriate and i
accept there'll be some where they're
not
and we're aware of a number of
significant ones where they do apply
across the boards
so personally i would prefer to see that
option still available
thank you phillip
john
thank you just to clarify
while i uh
may have missed it coming in a wee bit
late through that workshop side of
things
the art um just to use one example for
example the art
show here in carboy
um
i believe this
for a number of years that has been
funded
wider throughout the district how do you
see that happening in the future well
what has happened there john is that we
actually were asked
by this community board to make an
application to the mayor
or to the council about getting
regular funding
and that's happened so we no longer will
be applying the arts trust will no
longer be applying to the community
board for that funding it's coming
direct from the council from the fund
but from all four boards okay appreciate
it yeah so another
the same thing potentially could happen
to some others which is what nibbles
neville's joining that yeah into the
future yeah fine thank you appreciate it
okay anyone else like to come
all right well we'll
put the motion then
receiving the report
uh retains the status quo and
uh
d the new part moved by neville seconded
by al all those in favor
aye against
carried
what was that
one against okay right brent voted
against like that noted
thank you
right item number six
the recommendations for speed limit
changes so we've got joanne
and ali welcome
all right good evening everyone so the
purpose of this report is to update the
board on the results from the recent
speed limit consultation and obtain a
recommendation for council
the consultation was carried out over a
three week period and overall 297
submitters provided feedback
we also sought feedback from key
stakeholders like the new zealand police
wakakotahi and various other
organisations
as you can see from the results the
majority favoured lower speed limits in
kaivoi and tuahiwee areas with some
mixed results on the roads which border
with the rangyara ashley community board
area
the recommendation in this report does
include all the speed limits proposed
and technical reasoning has been
provided in section 4 as to why this is
to ensure consistency along the flexton
skew bridge road corridor we have
recommended that the speed limit is
reduced to 80 kilometers per hour on
flaxseed road also
noting that there is insufficient length
to retain 100 kilometers per hour speed
limit on this road within its current
bounds
the setting of speed limit rule requires
two kilometres of length for this speed
limit and as such it would encroach onto
scubage road or extend it in the current
80 kilometers per hour zone on flaxstone
from this the recommended option is to
prove is to provide a recommendation
with all of the proposed speed limit
reductions
happy to take any questions
thank you
anyone any questions
i have a question about um
charles street i see their speed is 30
all the way to the ash keaton boat ramp
which is an awfully long way
how many speed bumps are there on that
trip
enough to slow people down
and there is also the chicane down or
part way down and then there's a very
tight bend and another tight bend around
into the escape and boat ramp so it
certainly it was always designed as a
low speed environment and this would
just help reinforce that right okay all
right
brent
no mihi madam chair following on from
your question madam chair in regards to
charles street why have you not extended
it
uh from
all the way from jolly all the way now
to william street because what i'm
finding is that that charles street is
becoming increasingly dangerous because
you've got traffic
coming out of where you pick up your
mail and people are actually backing out
the traffic new world is becoming more
popular yeah there's a lot more traffic
down there so
is there any reason why you've chosen
not to actually include all of charles
street from williams further down
towards asking please thank you
yeah so this was really i guess this
initial consultation was focused around
trying to
i guess reinforce the environment that
we had created down on the bottom end of
charles street
once we start looking at charles street
from
there through to williams street then
there's an argument for we should be
looking at the town centre as a whole
and what the speed limit is through the
town centre the same argument exists for
william street where we've got all the
raised platforms
um and should that be 30 and i think our
review of our town center cause as a
whole would be a future step for us and
we would do that at the same time
and would that be within the six months
then that is noted in e is that right
so no what is noted uh with an e is that
the
roads which would have a change speed
limit would require a follow-up survey
within six months
so that's just to check how
the speeds are sitting against what the
posted speed limit is
thank you
are there any other questions
all right who would like would someone
like to move 6.1
john you'd like to move 6.1
i'll second that
so john would you like to speak to it
certainly um
no matter what the roading team do what
we do as a community board council and
so on we're not going to feed everybody
all the time
there's some areas in uh you you've
touched on it
um
thank
you and i'd i'd just like to say that um
i think it's quite impressive the fact
that the consultation um
was reasonably positive
um just about all the speeds were
approved of at least by half the
population or the people consulted so i
thought that was very good
um all right so moved
ah never wants to say something it's
quite simple really won't be voting for
this in any state
thank you neville
and al you wanted to say something yeah
i'll just um i'll wait for it
there's a few idiosyncrasies in there
but i can live with them i'm very
pleased to see tram road
on the list there thank you joanne
hoping my life in my hands daily at
flackville school corner but of course
it all boils down to the enforcement
factor which i am skeptical about not
just tram road i mean the whole damn
thing it's all very well putting these
in but if they're not going to be
enforced um
the whole thing loses a lot of impact
doesn't it but that's that's a separate
issue
thank you
all right i'll uh i'll put the motion
by john
that the board
receives the report a b
where am i
a b c d and e
and second to buy me all those in favor
against
thank you
noted
carried
thank you very much
right the next item on the agenda is 6.2
pachina's walkway concept plan
tori
welcome tori
thank you
good evening um i am here to seek the
approval of
a concept plan for the upgrade of
patchiness walkway which i think you'll
know where it is it's just just out here
between
william street and the car park here
and this is following a request
to staff from autogena kaipoi to upgrade
the space and to create a space which
looks more permanent and aesthetically
pleasing
and there's
already
the sculptural elements within the
walkway which i've proposed to remain
and to remain
in the locations that they are but we've
included some seating
just to organize the space a little
better some garden beds
and just made the authority
excuse me the thoroughfare the walkways
a little easier to navigate
initially
six thousand dollars was requested
from the general landscaping budget for
this project given that it was it's just
a temporary upgrade of the space
i've requested an additional 1700
um that is to accommodate um
the my estimate for the project was 7
000 and includes another uh 10
contingency to ensure that we
we can do it within budget um so
i'm requesting
approval of the concept plan and the
additional
uh 1700
today
thank you
any questions
brent
now me madam chair um tori
can you explain what the gray is
is that just going to be remaining as
as it is in terms of the the rough
stones and that's the stuff what's going
to happen with that please
so you've got the walkway which is your
footpath on the northern side beside
uh
anz at the bank but what is the grey
that goes in between around where the
tree is and around where the raised
planters are
so i've proposed leaving the
walkway at the same grade at the same
level it gently slopes down but
to even it out and to cover in a fine
crusher dust or
or chip
my concern tori is that
this is like a wind tunnel
even if you go there today it's not so
bad but you've got easterlys which will
funnel straight down there and my
concern is that there is no wind break
there and i was thinking that you would
probably put wind break along that
eastern side to create some form of
shelter if you're going to be sitting
there and i yeah
that would
yeah i wasn't that keen on your design
in terms of i'm sorry just to put it out
there
because of the windbreak and the the
shelter bouts that would be required if
one was going to sit there so
is this just a draft or are you going to
still work on it
no i'm seeking approval of this concept
plan the reason i didn't put a
win shot or wind break in there is i
just feel it would restrict views into
the
land way too much and i would re really
be reluctant to do that for septe
reasons for safety
given there's no lighting
through the laneway
i just didn't feel that it would be safe
okay
i remember talking at one stage we were
going to do wires across and actually
put lighting across between the two
structures is that part of the design as
well or not
i haven't i i'm just quite restricted
with budget and i
i just don't think that we can achieve
the organization of the space
as a base really
before putting in
additional things such as that which
would be really nice to have but i i
just can't meet that
cool thank you
thank you madam chief oh
tori you mentioned it briefly in in the
report can you just just comment further
on the fact that this is
i'm thinking on friday the the concept
plan for the marina was released to the
public the this is this is temporary um
are you how are you comfortable spending
hour on something that
may not be there very long touchwood
it's your decision of course but i i
don't think we can achieve
i guess organization of the space or
beautifying it
any
anymore
with with any lower budget um
there's really not a lot that you can do
it's actually quite a big space it's 20
by 12 meters and just to to bring in a
new surface and tidy it up is going to
use a lot of that budget
um tori can you tell me do you know what
sort of tree they're going to be putting
in the middle
uh i hadn't established a species but i
was hoping to put something relatively
quick growing um and which will provide
a bit of
shade yeah
i'd
look towards a deciduous tree so it
gives
the shade in summer and
um doesn't doesn't make things too too
shady in winter right
any other questions
okay so
um
you've got a b c
d e f
g
would someone like to move
l you'll move it right so l will move
6.2 a through to g what do we have a
second
john you're a seconder okay all right
okay
john
happy all right okay so
um
brent
uh just based on what i've already said
all the questions i've raised with tory
in terms of the wind break and that's
the stuff i'll be voting against it
thank you
okay
all right
okay all those in favor then of 6.2 a to
g moved by owl seconded by john mayer
against
so carried all right thank you
right moving on to 6.3 kevin the kaiapoi
riverbank walkway memorial reserve
welcome kevin i believe this is the last
time we'll be seeing you
yes good luck with wherever you're going
squad yeah
and it's been a pleasure too thanks very
much
um
thank you madam chair good evening
everyone
i'll
take reporters red but um there is a
little bit more information i'd like to
share with you and just clarifications
from the report because as you could
probably appreciate it was a pretty
rapid put together from the last uh
meeting that we had
so i've got just a few items running
through here if you don't mind mhm
firstly
i attended a consultation meeting with
the return services association
executive board and we discussed the
concept plan
in a broad concept um
there was a fair bit of feedback
regarding that they did
generally opt for option b substantially
unchanged as it was showing but there
was feedback
requesting looking at some other items
that could be included within the design
remember this is only a draft concept
and it would go further to a developed
design
so those are the elements we discussed
that could be considered or integrated
with an accessible access from raven key
onto the reserve either by curb cut down
or some other means because it's quite a
dangerous curve
um definitely a need for additional
seating within the reserve
um
repairing the existing paved surface
that's there now because it's all over
the place
the budget allows for that stuff to be
lifted and relayed before we put any new
pavement down
also there's talk of an additional
flagpole at the eastern end
um
and all those points were noted down and
they would be considered
during the develop design process other
design elements that
could be included budget permitting
would be repair and upgrading
upgrade of the existing in-ground
lighting some of it doesn't work some of
it's um it's
it should be upgraded to led we're going
to be doing any landscaping in there now
is the time to do it
so yeah we don't have budget for that
but i
think that there's something that could
be considered
and also i'm not sure if everyone's
aware about the scent the center tap is
quite out of level it's about 70 ml
across on the diagonal outer level
i'm getting costings to the feet i'm
getting the feasibility study done of
that and costings for it um
it's sort of whether it is done or not
it
wouldn't have to be discussed
whether it's too risky to try and
re-level it
but um that is something else to look at
secondly
i have
emailed the ymca career access group
with the concept plan but unfortunately
because of the time
i haven't been able to get in front of
them
but we will be arranging a meeting with
the access group i think it's the 14th
of december
to discuss whichever preferred option
we go with and um yeah to get their
feedback on that
thirdly
the raven key road curve as as um
john you pointed out last time is quite
bad
it's not bad the whole way the first 10
meters from the garden is probably the
worst it's not actually like a nib kerb
it's just a
i'm sorry it's not a carbon channel
it wasn't really on radar roading's
radar
um because it wasn't a curving channel
and they considered it not to be forming
a drainage function however
with a site inspection it actually does
form a drainage function so there's
something to be worked through there
so
i've been discussing with them potential
options for improvements to the curb
and installation of the footpath as
shown on that concept plan
um
interesting that the
just
for your information it was identifying
the 2011
town centre plan is the key link and
that link down through the reserve was
one of eight core projects for the town
centre
it is also included in the walking
cycling walking and cycling strategy
what's the cycle route
yeah the strategy
for um
for an upgrade there so i think it's
quite a key point and
in considering the design um
i think yeah i'll get back to it both
time and that leads to my next point i
think we should take a wee bit more time
and just sort of breathe and take a
proper look
at how this whole thing functions
because i it is a key a key part
of the town centre
um
item 4.16
notes the year of construction this
project is not yet confirmed so it was
programmed to be built
in this financial year
however um with for various reasons it
looks like this
job may be a bit more complicated and
may uh
potentially might need more coordination
to achieve a better result um
so
apart from that i'm leaving as well so
sort of the staff resources sort of puts
a wee bit of a squeeze on that as well
because you know i'm not there to sort
of see it through
unfortunately
yes i delay
a slight delay and it may allow time for
more consultation or coordination
particularly with the raven key link
footpath and the lighting etc
so this recommendation is seeking
approval to to progress the design based
on draft concept plan b
that concept would remain regardless of
what happens on raven key the concept
plan would make more or less the same
there would be obviously more detail in
it the width of the footpath would
change whether the curve gets built out
further whether the parking gets looked
at
so what we're saying is for the reserve
space and identifying the key link
across raving down the rabbity footpath
is what this
report reporters seeking pre-blog
thank you have a nice question thank you
nibble
a couple questions
the procedure moving forward i mean
obviously with the elements that kevin's
talked about
maybe i'd want to see
what the dollars are around that for a
full project
and
the second question that really um and
it's up to us of course but whether the
board would go to council to actually
fund the project of that size and see
whether that could be done
but what would be the procedure now to
do what kevin was just sort of talking
about really i mean without progressing
the plan i think that
what's the process too
if we were to do nothing with this
well if that's the case then
um it's unlikely that we'd get onto it
in this financial year
and so the money would be carried over
into the next financial year
which has been this money's been
allocated in the budget for a number of
years so that's not an issue we'd have
to go to
roading and work with them on what the
best design was for that treatment and
then come to the annual plan and seek
additional funding through the ending
plan to be able to do that
and see we're also fitted in with
roading's program as well identifying
the money to be able to do something
doesn't necessarily mean that it can be
done with the resources that we have so
we need to look at the program as well
there is options to do it in a staged
approach as well
you could do a portion of it
and just exclude at the moment
the footpath which is on the roading
side and
create the footpath on the top side redo
the paving
etc etc and then
spend most of the money and then look to
do the curb
um at a later date rhodium said that the
road's quite wide there so there is the
option of pushing that
out slightly into the road
one to be able to live it level it off a
little bit more
but also create a little bit of a larger
um walking and cycling path through
there so
look we don't want to go ahead and do it
without
looking at that um opportunity first so
i think we need to do that and that's
um that as long as well as resourcing is
really driving
us to say look we're not going to get it
on for the samsung day
so it's going to have to be
we're going to have to do more work and
come back to this board with some proper
costings prior to the long annual plan
so
even this won't get done
if we were to pass it today as it is
without any other alterations wouldn't
be done before anzac day would have the
resources if you staged it yeah you
potentially could get some of it done
but you wouldn't get it all done um you
wouldn't get most of the stuff which is
connecting to the road um would have to
just wait but you could stage the other
stuff at the top it means that you have
to do construction twice
it does mean that the overall project
ends up costing more
because you've got to have png
twice
you've got to have tindering
so it ends up being a lot more staff
time a lot more disruption for the
etc community
it's better to do it all at once
absolutely
so procedure-wise chris are we better
off
to lay it on the table until the
beginning of the financial year um well
yes but the recommendations at the
moment they only us approve staff
proceeding with further design of option
b so we're sort of saying look let's
make a decision about an option option a
and option b
um we're not actually saying that we're
going to um build it you're not giving
us approval to do that it's just
approval to go option b root as opposed
to option a route with further design of
option b and the connection with the
road to come back to the board
that's actually all you're approving
today
thank you
any other questions
so someone prepared to move
yes philip i'm not moving nope
[Laughter]
uh kevin
the two roasted on the eastern west
frontage of raven cage
under
option a and b
do they remain yes they do
uh substantially the one to the west
would be uh made slightly smaller those
roses will be relocated within the
reserve
that's only to enable a linking path
from the new path within the reserve out
to the road edge
without going through where the flagpole
is
okay thank you
or maybe the second man right so moved
by brent a through to f
um seconded by neville brent you'd like
to say anything
okay neville anything to it yeah look
i think the project is bigger than what
you've got here i think kevin's
absolutely right to point it out and
particularly around that curving in in
cycling
um they're the two major elements that
need
a little bit closer looking i think i
think this the walkway is adequate if
you want to walk along
the top of the bank you know um that can
be tightened up pretty easily i think
and what we can do around the cenotaph
and and certainly leveling it there's
something that we need to have a look at
i think you'll um
you'll need your shock absorbers when um
when you have a look at it because i do
remember the prices of actually caging
it shifting it and doing all those
things in the first bit so please be
sitting down when they give you the
price for that
um
but um
i think it's it's necessary that the
full project if we're going to do an
overhaul we need to do one
not just do
bits and pieces and and so on to get it
done i think we need to do it and do it
properly
thank you um john and then al
thanks very much look i can appreciate
the um
well
the patience of the vrsa team
you know
to to
fix this
um
looking at the plan and now that the the
uh
the potential to do that uh
the
the roadside
um the curving
i've watched like a lot of people
in this town for a number of years
elderly people have a great deal of
difficulty getting up
to get the benefit of that area
they've got to walk a long way down to
the bridge to get you know or have help
to get up on that step and so on
it's such a great spot
um
and there's a lot a lot of this town i'm
so so proud of
that little corner
um
but i think we've got to do it right and
and i know there's going to be time
involved and so on but i think that
the artistic skill of the team
and
you know just
meeting all those needs for the excess
you know people in wheelchairs and all
that sort of thing
making it
really positive for the future thank you
thank you john
yeah i agree with the um we need further
costings of this this thing could run
away with us i was there on thursday
with along with philip for the um
commemorative service the 11 11 service
and i stood there for an hour looking at
it at the end of the hour i thought why
are we doing this at all actually i was
heading towards option c this thing is
okay as it is why are we spending 135
altering it it doesn't actually need to
be done and that money which is regen
the sort of the tail end of the region
money could go back to murphy park and
and be put into the
rowing concept plan on the edge of
murphy so
i'll lukewarmly support the motion today
to proceed but i'm i just foreshadow i
may not i may not vote for it when it
comes back
brent and then phillip
you go first
oh right yes
uh thank you madam chair i endorse
councillor blackie's comments i think
this is a very unique and special part
of kyopa and i actually quite like it
how it is
i think it needs some maintenance but
may not need a total revamp
i'm just a wee bit concerned that we may
be trying to introduce too many new
elements with walking and cycling and so
on through this really passive reserve
and
its main purpose really is the cenotaph
and it is used regularly
by the resa for those associated events
so i'm not necessarily against looking
at alternatives but i just urge caution
really and not want to rush into
anything
and
really i was there on thursday too and i
must admit it's a little area of kaya
boy i quite enjoy
thank you
right of reply brent thank you madam
chair the reason why i am moving this is
because of the wonderful support that we
as a community give to the rsa and the
wonderful
service that the
the rsa gives to the community and my
only concern with that whole area and it
certainly does need a re redesign
is the traffic management issues and
that's the stuff with more and more
people attending these services and i
think that with our landscape team we
could really come up with something
fantastic so as it becomes even a better
place to visit
but at this stage it is just a draft
concept plan and i look forward to
seeing
the final plans coming back to the board
thank you madam chair thank you
all right
i'll move the motion 6.3 i'm sorry i
mean moved by bran seconded by nibble is
that right yeah
all those in favor
against
carrot well it sounds kevin is if you've
got a lot more
someone has got a lot more work to do
but it won't be you so all the best with
your new job thank you okay all of you
thanks for all your good work
thank you great pleasure
right item 6.4 the kaipou river marine
precinct swimming facility grant and
hannah rose
welcome
hello hello
just in case you're wondering it's grant
mcleod under here
not one of the other
grants not one of the other grants um
thank you
for receiving the report um you'll note
that we did a little bit of a workshop
on this at the last board meeting plus
there has been a number of conversations
over the last sort of 12 to 18 months
around what we're going to do to resolve
the conflict that we've currently got
within
the river area
since we actually met at the workshop
we've had some contact from ecan
which has actually been rather useful
for us in terms of clearing up a couple
of the things that we thought we were
trying to resolve
one of the things that they've actually
pointed out to us is there's a new
marine
officer on board called john kent
and he's actually pointed out that one
of the issues that we've currently got
is that the swimming activity around
parts of the working
pontoon area
are actually in breach of
the navigation safety bylaw in
particular 4.15
one of the issues that he can have
identified with that is that you can't
impede the operation of the boats
especially around some of those areas
that to a certain extent has
swayed officers in terms of what our
recommendation to you would be
um moving from looking at how we might
be able to provide a safe swimming spot
within there um to actually complying
with some of the things that our
regional council have actually been
telling us now
with some of this information that
they've been putting forward
so
we are going to be having some further
meetings with the ecan
offices just to kind of talk about how
that might look from a monitoring or
even going further than that an
enforcement perspective
the recommendation you'll see within the
report that officers have
uh put forward is actually to prohibit
swimming within this area
now whilst that's
possibly not the optimal outcome for
recreation
as you can see from some of the things
that i'm saying here
we have a general responsibility that
we've got there plus there's also an
expectation from
uh boat operators and also from the
harbour master as well
who actually regulate this site
um
that would then mean that we would have
to put some of the funding that we've
got set aside for this project into
planning how we do an education program
around this or
how we actually ensure that there's
compliance with uh with an outcome of
this nature
as i say we had hoped that we would be
able to come up with some form of
intervention which might provide for
a recreational activity to occur there
one of the good news stories out of this
is that
we are linking in our youth advisor
with the aqua park
proposal
and they're actually working across each
other in terms of how we might engage
the youth to
still offer them some form of
recreational opportunity
should this recommendation actually be
supported
so look i'm happy to take questions
based on on what i've just said and
thank you
all right thank you grant um sandra
when you were talking to ecan did you
broach the subject that in fact this is
a designated swimming spot in the
cannibal land of water regional plan and
under pc7 and was supported throughout
the whole
uh no but that's a further that's a
further conversation that i could um
that i could raise with them as they've
pointed out because there's active boats
in there
it immediately brings into place the
navigation safety bylaw
so there's clearly some policy layering
going on there that i need to um debunk
with
and it was endorsed uh by the zone
committee
and as a recreational slang spot because
of the
use over the
decades uh generations
i i would i would have to explore if he
can as to which one of those policies or
because
if you have a look at pc7 you'll see
probably so that's a plan change yeah
okay that goes to ecan um
for ratification on wednesday and we had
the opportunity of um
of submitting on it
it was supported by the community
alastair told me this morning
sounds like there might be a change
any other questions
i'd like to see which one overrules
which one because i would imagine the
navigation and safety rule would
well and truly out run pc7 but i mean
the clarification sound is right the
clarification on that is what we need to
need to know it's not uncommon to see
that sort of policy layering come into
it
within a recreational area
generally health and safety or a bylaw
would trump most other
forms of legislation or policy that
might exist
brent
thank you grant uh
there were three young men jumping into
the water today
who's going to do you really believe
that the
installation of signage is actually
going to
stop these young people from jumping
into the river
thank you
signage has a limited impact on people
and if that's all that you're going to
rely on to try and change behaviour then
yes it will fail
the reality is we're going to need to
work with ecan and also with the local
community
that's why emily belton from the
community team
is working with the local youth still
and also across with the aquaplay
providers
um there
whilst we might prohibit it here the
reality is
we are going to need to do some form of
active management with
the people who still want to conduct
that activity um what it means is that
it's a little bit more straightforward
for when
people who don't appreciate that
activity are actually calling it in um
there's a little bit more of an avenue
there for them to actually complain
through the police and also to the
harbour master
if i could just ask sort of elaborate
elaborating on that point so what sort
of clout does ecan have when they have a
by-law what what happens to people when
they break the bylaw
we have seen ecam prosecute people under
a bylaw previously um unfortunately in a
situation like this uh
you would hope that it would be
uh preventative rather than reactive
because reactive would probably mean
that something has occurred in terms of
an accident or some form of harm
but that's something that we'd be
talking and addressing with ecan anyway
thank you okay any other comment
right neville happy to move seconded by
owl
all right that where are we 6.4 a
through to g
level
this is something that i don't really
want to move to be honest i don't want
to
see the kids or
some of them aren't kids jumping off the
bridge
it's it's it's something i don't want
but equally i don't see so want to see
someone with the boat prop through the
head
and uh i have seen that in the past and
it's not a very pleasant sight
not only that you've got commercial
operators within the within the wharf
area and that's from coast guard through
to um
through to the bridge
i myself met with um the ecan
the new weekend uh enforcement officer
who uh talked about uh the fact that
they do they can find now and they do
the problem we've got of course is that
um as long as they're in the water then
they can do their enforcement as soon as
they hit the shore then it's a police
problem so
you can you don't have to say any more
than that to see what's going what's
going to happen or how it works um it's
not going to be an easy thing to do
but
we would be absolutely foolish given
that we now have and we'll intend by the
end of february you're going to have a
full wolf with skiffs going through it
all summer
um it's going to be quite busy there and
that was our intention when we built
this thing that was our intention just
to have it quite busy um the unintended
consequence has been swimming
and um i mean
it comes in years and in other years
some years there's people swimming in
there and some year years there's not
it's just the way it's been all their
life it was a working port before
and when the boats used to sit and there
was 126 ships supplied this river and
when they were the size of the tuhoy
then um i can guarantee you they weren't
swimming in there when they were using
this port
because you couldn't you couldn't stop
them
they didn't have the means of navigation
that you have today
um
and with with the ships that were here
they just yeah so you couldn't get out
of their way as such so while they were
operating they certainly weren't
swimming in there but at other times
they were you know um
and i think pc7 i don't think that
that's an issue under the navigation and
safety laws i also run four other
marinas to see what they do
and
what is recommended here is exactly what
they do
napier being one of those that have
similar issues to what we have
and um
they've uh certainly trying to curb
those issues
at the present time they have they've
quite a few because they've three or
four different port areas where they've
fishing over here recreation over here
and then commercial over somewhere else
so they have quite a large area as you
can probably imagine that they
don't allow swimming in
so
but of course
the actual enforcing of it is the issue
not not the rule itself
um and
there you know there's plenty of room in
the river apart from there so
i mean so we'll see how the behavior
goes but grant is absolutely right we
will need to do some work
as will other enforcement agencies to
try and get people to uh
to work with it to make it work properly
thank you nibble
oh
you're little to add grant and neville
have covered that pretty well we are
between a rock and a hard place here um
we don't want to be anti-fun police but
um everything is trumped by the by the
health and safety thing as neville has
said no marina that doesn't mean and we
have no no choice but to comply with it
i didn't know what sandra brought up
before but i'm i'm guessing grant's
writing when he says that the health and
safety angle the marina angle will trump
the swimming designation thing but we'll
need to we'll need to sort that out the
signage thing yeah the signs aren't the
signs not this isn't going to solve the
problem it's going to be an ongoing
enforcement thing um and of course that
that relates to the youth of today um
who haven't got a hell of a lot of
respect for authority if we had a
disciplined youth of 30 years ago to be
a lot easier to make this thing worse
because it could clip somebody around
the air and and they might do as they're
told
although some of the operators they have
threatened to do that there's not really
an option in this day and age so
yeah we have we have no choice but to go
with us and uh good luck
all right
any other comments
okay move no motion all those in favor
against carried
good luck grant
thank you
6.5
the community hub
rachel and tara
welcome
good afternoon
um the purpose of this report is to
update the border on progress towards
the development of the chi point
community hub in the cryopoi south
regeneration area
i'm going to speak to the work done to
date
with the hub user groups and progress
with the longer term nature of the
project
um tara will then update you on the
plans for consultation and resource
consent
for the last six months we've been
meeting with the three key user groups
monthly to work alongside them in
establishing the best long-term
governance structure for the hub and in
regards to concept design adaptations
following the residence workshop
the way the user groups and staff have
considered these concerns as identified
in attachment 1 of this report the final
draft concept plan is also attached
attachment 3 shows the common vision
values and purpose for the hub the user
groups have worked on together
vision to be a thriving hub of activity
learning and connection for kaiapoi
mission statement by the community for
the community
all alongside holding the values of
connection resourcefulness accessibility
service and making a difference
during this process of design
relationship building getting to the
core purpose of the hub it became
obvious there was need for a clear
unified governance structure
in discussion with funders and looking
at the options the user groups decided
the best way forward was to establish a
community trust to manage the hub
this decision was not come too lightly
as the groups had to consider building
ownership their individual
organisation's needs all whilst holding
the hub's purpose for the kaiboy
community at the centre
staff see this as a huge step forward
for the project because this
collaboration and consideration of the
bigger picture establishes a very robust
and strong foundation for the kaiapoi
community hub
it
also creates one funding application for
the external funders
which they prefer and enables the trust
to develop its own funding strategy for
the long term that would also enable
local business support and engagement
these monthly meetings will continue
into the future until the trust is
established and the project is up and
running
tara
hi um so i'm just going to talk about
what we're planning consultation wise
so um consultation we're looking to run
that 17th of november to the 13th of
december
and so we're at the moment putting
together a leaflet which will be dropped
out in an addressed envelope to
residential areas around the area um
we'll also have the usual let's talk
page
and we're going to run another
drop-in session where the community can
come along at the moment we're looking
at
it's thursday the 2nd of december and
late afternoon to catch people after
work so we're talking about we might do
a
barbecue
and we'll redo the model that we used at
the last session with the community
that reflects the updated plan
and marking out on site
the sizes of each of the areas so that
people can actually walk around and
really understand where things will sit
and how big they are
we're also going to talk to the
community about the playground
so at the workshop or drop in we'll
have some
big pages with different types of play
whether it's swinging sliding climbing
and we'll get people to
get their children to help us mark up
their top three things they'd like to
see in the new playground as well
once we've run through that process
we'll come back to the board with the
results of that consultation and the
feedback that we received
we'll also work quite closely with any
other residents who are still concerned
about the updated plan so we'll have
that ability to actually have one-on-one
meetings with them if we need to to
really understand their concerns in more
detail
and then that information will help with
our resource consent application because
we can provide a summary of that
information through that process as well
and then the community gets another
opportunity
through that process
to provide some further feedback
and i think that was about it so
happy to take questions thank you i
think that's a
great consultation i have to say i think
you've done a fantastic job in this
whole project any questions
all right well i'm very happy to move
this um
thank you brent um yeah as i say i think
you've done a fantastic job i think it's
great that it's going to be a trust i
think that's absolutely perfect it's a
win-win situation all round
those groups are going to have a
much better chance at getting funding
they don't have to worry about
handing on you know if they fold up well
it doesn't matter i'm sure as a group
it's a lot more satisfactory to be part
of a trust and they can all work
together as well
and i thought the plan was very good i
liked the fact that now you've moved
things away from the houses far more so
i'm hoping that you'll find that um
there's little opposition to this so i'm
very happy about this
brent would you like to speak to it
madam shear i think this is going to be
a positive asset for the comedian
congratulations to the team for putting
it all together so well done thank you
all right so all those in favor of a
through to e
against carrick well done thank you
thank you thank you
right 6.6 we've got two grant um
discretionary grant applications
requested by the clarkville play center
towards the purpose of a mud kitchen and
ground cover for their outside play area
we'll do them one at a time shall we
anyone like to speak to this do they
want do you want to pass it or decline
it
yeah
sorry yes debate the discussion yeah
madam chair i i have a few
um
doubts about this i mean i've talked to
people in the last couple of days
involved with it with the with this play
center because when you look through
there the um figures they presented
they've got eighteen thousand dollars in
the bank and i'm and so i went to them
and said is this a
is this a
business
business isn't quite the right word but
i said is that because it's not a it's
obvious not a money-making thing but on
the other hand it's not a volunteer-run
um
community
project either and i couldn't get a
clear answer but i just i'm just not
sure
that an outfit with that amount of money
sitting in their accounts
um
should be coming to council and it sort
of goes back to what we discussed in the
workshop about
um
whether or not the the intent of of
these fun this this funding process is
to give it to
financially secure outfits like this
okay i should have let you
talk to this we just sort of i felt we'd
already done it you know before but
any other comments then on this cart
will play center one
it does seem to go against what we
decided before doesn't it level well
again on top of that madam chair i see
that
there's a project also funded by the
oxford board
for 210 dollars
and 20 march 2021
um
this particular
place center sort of sits right on the
boundary
which is why they can either go yeah
right
okay right
would someone like to
either
approve or decline it
more discussion anyone like to say
anything else al obviously isn't in
favor
john i'm prepared to test the
test group and
move
forward
is there a second
no second
okay so it lapses for one for a second
oh phillip
i was just going to comment madam chair
that this highlights the difficulties of
sort of funding educational
groups yes and
i i don't get a vote so i don't know
what the answer will be but that is
something we did talk about earlier and
where is that line drawn and it's a bit
of a grey area um
it is
um
i can't can i can i
can someone decline it
a and c
so what time i'd like to do that
i'll second that
all those in favor
against carried
okay
so that was declined
so then we've got d
and e
480 so okay do you want to say something
about that one
um
no
pretty straightforward they just want to
put up a community pantry
which will benefit not only the
community itself but
any visitors that happen to be driving
through and need
some resources
and i thought it was quite reasonably
priced
for
for something that will give benefit to
a lot of people
um
okay
they put a labor in there do the men's
sheds usually
usually charge
obviously materials do they usually put
a labor
content in a price
all right
yeah brent
thanks madam kay have they gone to the
community and asked as to
whether or not there's any builders or
something like that out there that
actually can do this work uh situation
with the fruit and veggie stand at the
food forest i just put it on facebook
and broadhurst builders made the
approach and said would would build it
for free or they built it for free
so have
the pines cracky have they done the same
but i can
subject
to that question being passed or leave
it lying on the table whichever you
prefer
thank you i actually attended the
meeting
i'm the
rep for the board
when they brought this up and they are
trying to
what would you say develop the community
spirit
and that's where this is coming
from it's meant to be seen as a meeting
place for people you know well like the
food for us works
so i think their hearts are certainly in
the right place on this yeah
all right thank you
d
all those in favor
against carrot all right thank you very
good okay
all right 6.7 k again the meeting
schedule just yeah that's just the
annual report at the end of every year
but putting in place your meeting dates
um
for the following year so
pretty pretty self-explanatory
in regard to
venue
as you're aware we've had a bit of a run
around
trying to find alternative venues i'm
sure the library is functional again
fully functional
i opted not to actually include that in
the
report as it is ongoing
an ongoing issue and i'm hoping that by
january we'll have some certainty
okay yes hope so
all right so i'll move um that the board
receives the report a and b
a second of please
seconded by al all those in favor
against carrick thank you
right correspondence we've had a letter
um
long-term plan response which is
attached at the end i hope you've all
read it three pages i don't think we'll
read it now um so it's just a matter of
accepting that
but that we received that correspondence
so i'll move that a seconder for that
and that's seconded by neville all those
in favor against carried
i haven't got much to report the
chairperson's report i have to say it's
been the quietest month i've ever known
everything's cancelled nothing's
happening anymore i'm so over it
one good thing i could report is that
the waimakuri arts trust are going to
donate ten thousand dollars for a
sculpture and a sculpture has been
chosen
it's twice that amount so we're going to
have to raise some money and that's what
the waimakariri public arts trust role
is anyway
and it's a raymond herber it's in the
shape of a tree
he's got one at his um
sculpture park and ram paddock road in
what in the white gorge in the quarry
um it's up on a hill there and it's a
tree blown by the north west and it
actually pivots
that's the one there thank you chris
yeah it's very cold so it's four metres
high
it's quite big and it the wind will
swing it around a little bit so at the
moment the trust
both the waimakuri arts trust which runs
the art expo and the public arts trust
which decides these things
are working together with um
grant mccloud
with the council to find the best
location so if you've got any ideas
about where you'd like to see it i'd
really like to see it in a really public
place
that people see either entering or
leaving caipor maybe
somewhere like that so anyway that's up
for discussion at the moment so that's
really exciting
that's all i've got to report so um
we'll start with you nibble
oh sorry we're not ready for that yet
i've got to do these things
[Laughter]
well it says a verbal update will be
given yeah
okay
all those in favor
again
right
item nine matters for um information
there
do we have to move those
okay all those in favor against carrick
excluded report 9.7
has anyone received any information no
we have so i talked to jared about this
morning and he was a little bit
um confused and said that
you weren't going to receive
if you hadn't received the information
by now you would receive the information
by the next meeting
however he was having a look to see what
information was actually going to come
here as opposed to council because i
believe that there was some publicly
excluded stuff in there which didn't
need to come to the board and um was
more important to go to council so
um i think he might be writing a memo to
give to the board for the next meeting
um as opposed to the council which will
receive all of the um information okay
all right so we don't worry about that
at the moment that's good
so moving on to ten their members
information exchange level
there's can manage here um
great christchurch partnership we've had
another workshop about spatial planning
and all of those things for
around greater christchurch and there'll
be information coming out on that
um
in the very near future just as they
move on you'll get some updates which
will come to you about
where that's heading and
we're have
we're in a bit of an awkward position
because with that spatial planning
because our district plan of course is
uh out for consultation and waiting for
for things to come in um and objections
or not so it's all a bit of a
chicken any bit of a scenario with
greater christchurch partnership
so
that's the main thing and
the transport which goes with that
so they're talking about transport
corridors
and
i think you need to keep your eye on
that because there's three suggestions
in there and one of them
one corridor passes kaiboy altogether
so it doesn't actually come in to kaipoy
and it's based on something that was
done
around auckland actually they used to
have sort of the hub and spoke
public transport system
and they've cut that back to just a
major route in everybody going to
a main spine heading through and that's
working quite well for them they've
they've um really picked up on their on
the public transport in the middle of uh
auckland on it so they're looking at
that it's not a it's not a given or it's
not even
it's just a suggestion at this time that
there's three or four different options
here that they're looking at
um social housing we've had workshop
phillips on uh on that as well we had a
couple of presentations one from kang
aura and one from
modus
but they're they're a
a private supplier of uh state housing
to their country now to uh or to the
country actually they do a lot of stuff
in
auckland and christchurch and uh have
inquired
uh of both
angora and
motors have inquired about what they can
do or if there's any partnerships they
can have not only in kaiapoi but around
the rest of the district to
help with social
housing
went to the uh
service in fact i um
gave a speech at the rangura service the
other day uh for the rsa up there uh in
light that dan was
down here so
however i managed to get back in time to
sort of catch up with people back here
so that was
interesting
attended zone five and six as did philip
we both went to that meeting with the
mayor
it was very interesting because we were
sort of in and out um having a look at
what we were doing three waters as we
were moving along but uh local
government new zealand uh basically fell
on this sword there and
apologized to phone zone five and six
for uh the way they'd committed to
three waters
and that their consultation in the
future would be a lot better than it has
been
and they need the approval of the sector
to do things rather than just introduce
it and then go say and say that's what
the what the sector wants to do so
that was rather interesting because it
almost was the start of the meeting it
was almost the end of the meeting and in
fact
alan pragnell was
introduced
by his boss as the antichrist so
i'm not sure i even want to be
introduced by the bosses there but
this is a lot really to where it was
heading
um
been sitting again with philip on the
hearing for
the winter's land under section 181
uh to do with the
feldwick drain and pump station
and some land that's there that's
required to
put a bun and so on and there to make
their work
so that hearing is actually in uh
just on hold at the moment for
deliberations a few things we're just
having a look at and we'll see where
that hits but we'll let you know where
that uh
where that gets to
um
and
no that little different i can't read my
own writing i wrote something else down
can't tell you what it is
thank you
i've got very little actually to report
we must have done something for the last
month but i'm not sure what the hell it
is
um i met with the wow guys down at
courtney lake with green space staff
in the middle of the week they're
closing in on their opening day is the
27th
i believe is that the saturday it's that
saturday anyway whatever i think it's
the 27th this month the the bouncy thing
the um
i'm not allowed to call it a bouncy
castle what do we call it
an aquaplay facility has arrived sitting
here and it's in christchurch ready to
blow up and we discuss with um
um we discussed access with the delta
guys were there and how that's going to
work with the car park
and um
the
while the whale guys are all over the
thing they're doing planting along the
lake edge to protect the lake edge and
they've even gone as far as bringing in
their at their expense bringing in soil
and filling in dips in the paddock on
the exit where the access track goes and
planting them so they're all over that
with their with their own working bees
so that's all let's all go um
that's pretty much me um the river
carnival um
is for march the 13th um
is on well we think it's on with martin
not here i was meant to discuss it
tonight with him but um as you know both
with the
um christmas parade cancelled
all our all our efforts will turn to
that um
covered permitting of course
um i'll tell you by do we have a meeting
in december we're coming back to you
should know by then um whether we're a
go or not because it's going to take
that's that's about our last chance to
say yes or no
um so hopefully we'll we're we're all go
and we can put a lot of the effort in
money that
was going to go into the um as i think
i've told you okay we've handed it to
kpa as opposed to our sort of
semi-autonomous river carnival which was
chris me and neville basically um
so kpa are
running it
um
that's about all that's about all i got
thank you al right
thank you madam chair um
i've already sent through my report the
thing is i've made a mistake with regard
to the neighborhood support agm it's
actually this wednesday and not thursday
it's at the rangiora council chambers at
7 30. in terms of the food forest whilst
events are really
iffy we're still running lots of
educational events particularly around
kumara mushroom growing and such like
and that's bringing a lot of people to
kaiapoi
like oxford garden group came the other
day and 30 ladies all then went off to
the cafes and the restaurants afterwards
spending their money in the town and
that's really the beauty of of having
this thing like a food forest apart from
that you can read my members
exchange online thank you very good
thank you good job
um
the same amount of excitement that we
had on our little stretch of channel
street that the nice little dogs lost
um
thank you madam chair uh neville said
quite a few of the things that
i was going to comment on so i won't say
any more about that
um
the council recently confirmed the
representation review and there are no
changes proposed to this ward it's now
gone to the local government commission
and objections
are open until the 8th of december
so we'll see where that ends up
unfortunately as you may know the enc
business awards have now been cancelled
the rescheduled event cancelled so that
was a bit unfortunate
along with the various christmas parades
and even out of pegasus christmas by the
lake is now off
um after i've been asked to be santa so
i miss out on that opportunity
um anyhow i don't know why they ask me
um
i went to um
i went to a staff farewell and uh one or
two staff have been moving along and we
recently had a meeting with some labour
mps to tell them about three waters from
our perspective and i think it was a
good meeting whether it sank in i don't
know
and the last thing i went to i think was
the armistice day service uh
without
and neville came later and um that was
held in this contentious little reserve
and that's it for me very good thank you
phillip
sandra um contrary to what mr brown says
pc7 is
um at an extraordinary ecan meeting on
the 17th that's still on the agenda
there and i had a i think i think
alistair might be confusing with um the
minister for the environments um gave an
extension to when um eking could deal to
it till
december the 9th and they've got a yeah
anyway it's out there and it's on the on
the
on the website it's a massive massive
document and
i've skimmed over it and i'm not
actually quite sure what i could tell
you too much about it except
um and this is before it goes to the
this is the commissioner's reports
um
they've replied uh to something like 700
submission points
but um the pegasus lake of interest is
um
deemed to be a stormwater treatment
basin and does not have to comply to
with the
recreational levels of saying that's an
a new thing
um
so as of um
as of the 17th we'll um
we'll hear from
the councillors um
considering it and i understand not all
councillors will be there some are
deemed to have a conflict of interest
but um remains to be seen
um
good progress on that
211 lower camside road there's agreement
with the
representative of the trustees to access
um through there
plant off the wetland fence and um
yeah offensive that gets you gets us to
the
uh the motorway bridge under which we go
and
get to the
planting area we already have done and
the residents around that loop
have had a change of heart and are
totally supportive of the
of the um
of the concept
and the planting they think it's really
good
um we've got um
the working party ticked off about six
to seven thousand plants on order uh
there's a bridge coming and
fencing we've got to bridge it with
curry carry over of 248 000.
and i think with all the things we
considered just last week we've probably
allocated
150 plus
and i'd hope be
hoping we can get through to
revels road bridge
by mid-year
there's
waimakari's first environmental
networking forum um which the council is
running and and i'm saying a few words
at um on november the 24th and
uh it's
by invitation um to community
environmental groups
and that's at main power um stadium
next week
and um if you want to um
have
a session on mahingokai and biodiversity
there's a workshop that eken is running
at the cuss community centre on friday
and you can have a farm visit after that
so yeah very good thank you
one thing i forgot to mention and that
is that the um
application from ravenswood
for the industrial era up there has been
turned down in its entirety
so that area will not um unless of
course they appear
they'll which i would guess they will
it's it will not go ahead
okay
all right thank you right so item 11
consultation projects there it's good to
see i saw some e-scooters today for the
first time too
so they look as if they're getting a lot
of use
there's 83ks in the first week
um okay so item 12 that's all right
board funding update board discretionary
grants got
5570 in it and the landscaping budget 25
430.
don't think we've got any media items at
the moment no questions
the